looks like this is going to be tougher
than we thought yeah I can't wait
[Music]
everybody it's Charlie this is going to
be my non-spoilery review of the Dragon
Ball super bro Lee movie
Funimation was nice enough to invite me
to the premiere it was a Mann's Chinese
Theater on the Hollywood Walk of Fame
which means that they went all out for
it Dragon Ball is one of the most
popular franchises around the world no
surprise that they spent all the money
to make it really awesome so it was a
really good time if you're new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the videos I know a lot of people are
wondering how the movie sets up
potential sequel series like people are
calling a dragon ball super 2.0 because
there's some new manga that's teasing a
new arc that they're gonna be covering
but I'll try to address that in as
non-spoilery away as possible the movie
itself just in general is meant to be a
bit of a creative soft reboot for the
franchise if you're really big fan and
you've been following the movie since
Dragon Ball super ended you probably
heard Toriyama talking about how they're
changing the way they animate Dragon
Ball they're going to a much more
classical style so if you're big the end
of the look of classic Dragon Ball and
you weren't so hot on what they did
during Dragon Ball super or you really
enjoy the look of the movie it looks
fantastic the way they go through their
different transformations they also go
above and beyond to make the colors pop
on screen it also helps that Broly is
green for the most part so if you're
familiar with any of the classic movies
there are a couple Broly movies
essentially they're just reimagining the
characters so even though the old Broly
movies were never canon if you ever
wondered if you had to watch those to
understand what's going on you
absolutely do not the film is filled
with Easter eggs for all the canonical
Dragon Ball series Dragon Ball Dragon
Ball Z Dragon Ball super so if you've
been a fan for a long time you really
enjoy a couple really cool montages
there are a couple time jumps during the
movie and they use those to lay in a
couple big references to stuff that
happened while Goku was growing up the
film is about an hour and 40 minutes
long so it's a little bit longer like
there's more stuff in it than you would
expect in a typical Dragon Ball film but
I think a lot of that is due to them
bending over backwards to try and
explain a lot of basic concepts who the
characters are just in case anybody is
going into the movie fresh and has never
seen dragon ball before so on that level
it actually did a really good job like
if you have somebody that you're trying
to introduce to Dragon Ball you can
actually start them on this movie but
like I said if you've been watching
every single series you will notice
Easter eggs for everything part of the
idea of this film is to sort of
creatively reboot the way things look
and the character dynamics for like the
next 10 years of Dragon Ball they
haven't said exactly what the next
series is going to be but everybody I
think is in agreement that something is
going to be announced sometime in the
next year as far as character work goes
I feel like they did actually really
good job with Broly
if you ever go back and watch Broly the
legendary Super Saiyan his motivation is
pretty hilarious typically you don't
watch those Dragon Ball movies for just
amazing Shakespeare level dialogue or
character motivation like you just want
to see them do really badass stuff so
without getting too nostalgic I'll say
this is definitely one of the best if
not the new best Dragon Ball film MVP of
the movie was definitely Broly he's an
actual interesting character in the
universe you genuinely walk out of the
movie excited to see where he's going to
pop up next and how he's going to deal
with all the pre-existing characters
that you've been watching during Dragon
Ball super
but Goku and Vegeta just have so many
amazing moments like if you really like
the dynamic that those two have there
are just some hilarious over-the-top
moments that we can't really get too
specific about just because of spoilers
but if you saw the last big trailer that
they released they were actually just
flat-out showing you exactly what was
going to happen they treated on a lot of
funny moments with their characters
trying to get to that big epic moment
piccolo has a lot of great moments if
you've seen all the trailers then you
know that we get to see Goku's parents
and like I said they're sort of soft
rebooting a lot of things within the
Dragon Ball universe so a lot of their
scenes take place during those sort of
reimagined origins of Planet Vegeta and
what happened to it there wasn't a whole
lot of character growth for Goku or
Vegeta or a lot of the returning
characters from Dragon Ball super like
it was mostly about Broly setting him up
so he got more story almost than Goku
and Vegeta did typically you spend most
of the time with those characters just
because they're the mains like they're
the big fan favorites but the film is
called Dragon Ball super Broly they gave
it that name because it's basically all
about Broly with some Goku and Vegeta
and the other characters in it so we
think lack of character development for
some of the other characters can be
forgiven in them wanting to spend so
much time with the Broly character it
just on a plot level I said they did a
pretty good job they use his character
to reimagine what happened to Planet
Vegeta
and freezes rolling all that without
getting into super big spoilers they
also use the story to retune a lot of
the character dynamics to go back to a
more classic place like we're talking
about animation going back to a
classical style the main character
relationships also sort of reset to a
more classic place after Dragon Ball
super because it was a whole lot of
stuff that happened with Frieza and the
other characters so there was a big
question about who the next big villain
was going to be Frieza is still the main
villain of the movie even though a lot
of the marketing makes you think that
Broly is the true villain but there are
a couple moral lessons that the film
tries to give you so it actually does
have something to say about the way you
raise people right versus wrong nature
versus nurture how friendships and
positive relationships usually win out
in the end and this is really optimistic
sense as you go into whatever the next
Dragon Ball series is going to be so
even though there isn't a traditional
post-credit scene like there's no end
tag or anything like that the film just
ends there's the credits and that's it
they do spend the last five to ten
minutes of the film letting you know
what each of the main characters goals
will be moving forward when we get a
little closer to the film being released
in theaters around the world I'll do a
video about the end of the movie and
what they tease for the next big series
because they're very specific there is
no question about what Frieza is going
to be doing what Vegeta will Goku what
Broly is going to be doing if you've
watched all the trailers and all the
promos there aren't that many huge
surprises there are a lot of funny
moments and it's mostly about the
character turns the only thing I wasn't
super happy about was the way they
resolved Broly versus Vegeta and Goku
without getting into spoilers you can
obviously see from the trailers that
most of the film is them beating the
crap out of each other in how powerful
Broly is even in his base form and just
how crazy he can get they do a good job
of actually explaining how his power
works and it's a little bit different
from the classic Broly film don't worry
if you haven't seen those the film
actually explains that there is dialogue
that they give two characters to sort of
highlight what's actually happening
while they're fighting each other but
based on a lot of the trailer footage I
had slightly different expectations
about how their fight would end so what
you do have a chance to see the movie
let me know what you thought of the
reboot and creative style and just
remember that whatever the next Dragon
Ball series is it will look kind of like
this now obviously it's a movie so they
probably spent way more time and money
animating this then they'll animate the
series but just in general this is what
we'll end up looking like so obviously
they're going to be hyping up the movie
for a long time they'll probably use
that time to get a little ahead on
whatever that next series is typically
what happens is is when animation gets
into later episodes the team falls
behind a little bit so every once in a
while you can find yourself with a break
in later runs but they haven't said
anything about how many new episodes
they're going to be or when it might
premiere so just post all your theories
in the comments below there is an
anniversary coming up so I'm expecting
that to make more announcements next
spring but just in general the film is
great and it will leave you very excited
for what's coming next and there is
definitely something that's coming next
so if you're worried that there wasn't
gonna be any more new Dragonball do not
worry about that anymore like I said
though when everybody else has a chance
to see the movie I might do a video
about the ending just because there's a
lot of really interesting stuff that
they set up so while you wait for
everything click here to watch all the
other Dragon Ball super Broly trailers
and click here for that brand new
Avengers 4 trailer video thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]